ukrainian president vladimir zolensky is
warning that if the violence gets worse
then new sanctions and an embargo on
russian oil is going to be needed his
predecessor petra poroshenko agrees that
tougher action is required to deal with
the russian president our special
correspondent alex crawford spoke to him
and has the latest from near kiev
there's about eight houses here that
have been flattened utterly flattened
there were about six people from one
family who died here
three of them were children one of about
12 years old the other one i think was
also an older teenager
unbelievably a couple of civilians
survived the people that we've been
talking to who are picking through the
rubble
and you've got to remember this is an
entirely residential area it's filled
with farm houses and homes
they say that they're now reduced to
trying to find just any documents or any
bits of possessions for the one of the
men who managed to survive one of the
men of the family who managed to survive
there were two two of the grandchildren
were staying in that partially um
standing building there who also managed
to survive
but look at what these bombs have done
and they they the people who were around
the village spoke of hearing three
really loud explosions
as as bombs were dropped and the they
they're obviously now utterly terrified
they this happened a couple of days ago
on friday
they're still reeling from the shock of
it all and i think it follows a pattern
of an increasing number of civilians and
civilian targets or civilian locations
which appear to be um targeted or
certainly not
um off the agenda of the the the russian
war machine
here they i told you they're trying to
pick through the remnants of whatever's
left here just to find official
documents and um anything that um
that the family that the family members
who've survived can grasp onto and a
number of these are um i think this this
gentleman is a is a relative um we spoke
to them earlier they they only speak uh
ukrainian but they were saying about how
they've spent the past couple of days
just sifting through
all of this
um and trying to make sense of what
happened there
they're pretty much in shock to be
honest and very concerned about the
the increasing
what they see and perceive as increasing
attacks
the woman that you see there who's been
going through
all the rubble um had some pretty choice
words for the um the russian president
um when when i asked her about what what
she she thought about was happening in
this area and we know that yesterday we
were in a completely different area
where um civilians who were trying to
flee an active combat zone were being
fired on as they were trying to flee so
there is no civilian at the moment in in
ukraine who feels particularly safe at
the moment there are no international
laws it seems which are being observed
and a lot of
anger and hesitation earlier we were
talking to the former ukrainian
president petra polish poroshenko who
was
on the one hand saying how grateful he
was
to britain america a number of other
countries um in the west who have
rallied to ukraine's support but also
demanding so much more
urging so much more action saying that
he he was incredibly bullish about the
prospects of ukraine
actually succeeding in this um david and
goliath battle you know because the
ukrainian military is pretty much
dwarfed by the russian one and uh the
numbers of of russian soldiers but he
feels that they have the courage the
determination the defiance however
he says they need
so much more they need
aircraft they need the fly the skies to
be closed he's demanding he they want
more weapons they want
much more unified response basically
from the international community and he
had some fairly cautionary and chilling
words about how this you know this isn't
just ukraine's fight this is the whole
world's fight he believes it's a real
um defense
of democracy and freedom and he felt
like uh
the reticence of the rest of the world
not to get involved he felt was almost
foolhardy because sooner or later he
said they are going to get involved
the rest of the world is going to get
involved unless
the russian leader is stopped but
this this is a
scene of utter utter and complete
devastation and nowhere have we seen
anything that even comes close to a
military target